All right. Hello everybody. Um, welcome.
Thank you for taking the time to listen
to us go through some learnings, lessons
learned, and then some really cool
architectural choices that we ended up
making. Um, we'll be discussing how we
essentially our journey and how we got
to improving first party van discovery
using LLM. I'm Justice Cassell. I'm here
with my awesome co-orker and counterpart
Scott Barren's here. Um so we'll go
ahead and uh get started.
So uh we'll take everybody back. I think
a lot of us you know security focused
folks, security researchers, folks that
are passionate about exploit development
or vulnerability discovery. When these
models dropped initially we were like
can we actually find vulnerabilities
with this? We're just asking it for
things and it's doing the thing. This is
the future. It's now it's great.
Phenomenal. So we started out you know
simple prompting thinking that we've you
know we've we've broken the barrier and
everything is going to be great. Um and
then we kind of realized that it's a
little bit more difficult than that. Um
you know consistency was difficult,
variance was huge, false positives kept
coming up. Um you know sometimes it
would ignore entire vulnerability
classes. Um got a little bit more
depressing and you know we realized you
know as folks that like to solve
problems were kind of in that space of
you know one more prompt we'll be able
to figure this out. Um but definitely
definitely definitely took a hit to the
dopamine for sure. So today u we have
phenomenal models that will continuously
and keep getting better and you know we
are in a different spot. So scanning and
discovering vulnerabilities is feasible
now. It is getting a lot better and
we'll continue to do so and you know we
always want to strive for that full
comprehensive coverage. We want all the
vans scan all the code see all the
things. Um but there's trade-offs to be
made when we're doing that right and it
is possible now to get this full
coverage and we'll kind of cover a
little bit of how that's possible and
what what the differences are but it
does cost a lot of money. So, there's a
lot of architectural trade-offs
depending on what you're willing to
accept and the and the architectural
choices that you make. Um, so an
overview of kind of what we want to
share here today.
Pardon me. We want to share, you know,
our evaluation, the things that we went
through um to get to more a better place
from an architectural perspective for
first party discovery. Um, the
techniques that are worth trying, the
things that we were considering of like
antiatterns, things prevent you all from
kind of falling into the same pits that
we fell into. We'll share some of the
demoralizing moments and the this is
absolutely tragic feelings that we got
into. Um, and then we'll demo a bit of
our in-house implementation that we're
working on for our productionization and
then we'll also share some uh workflows
and skills that emulate the testing and
benchmarking that we did so that folks
can kind of do this testing on their own
and evolve and see what works best as
the models continue to evolve as well.
Um, some caveats, we're focusing
entirely on anthropic based models
today. Um mainly obviously internally we
do a lot more iteration and a little bit
more testing but from a reproduction
perspective we wanted to make sure that
everybody could dive in and do their
thing um with kind of the tools that
we'll be we'll be sharing. Um the
evaluations we say directionally useful
mainly because um we have some you know
management in the in the audience that
might not be happy if we were running
40,000 iterations of some of these test
cases. Um but these are things that we
found that are very useful for us. And
then limitations will highlight you know
the things we don't know and things we
want to dive into. And then iteration
iteration iteration there's always a
better way. So if you find one, please
let us know. Um so our goals for this
have always been the same. We want to
review less more. Um by that we want to
highlight, you know, contextual
prioritization. So we want to look at
the things that actually matter to us.
Um we don't want, you know, database
management software getting flagged for
SQL injection vulnerabilities if that's
not actually a vulnerability, if that's
just a use case, right? Um and then we
want repeatability and determinism. So
we'll highlight some programmatic use
cases and ways we've reduced
determinism, but also um you know ways
we focus on getting those false
positives out and highlighting only the
vulnerabilities that we want to spend
the time looking at.
So um we'll cover the timeline. Our
research kind of began, we'll take it
back to like February 2025, uh where we
were first first round, first iteration
looking at, you know, okay, we can just
take this brick of text and pump
vulnerabilities out of this this genius
model, right? Um and then we were like,
okay, well, new features kept dropping.
There's orchestration now. We can do
file tracking. We can do state tracking.
We can do tracing. We can integrate with
our existing tools. This is looking
awesome. And then we're like, okay,
internal stack changes. is we want to
adopt to that. So we move to the IDE
what we're using now. So we switch our
architecture around a little bit. We're
like okay we're still getting pretty
good results. There's a lot more work we
could do. And then we shift again
because we realize we need to be ID
agnostic. So we go to an MCP. We start
doing context injection, right? And then
finally we land in this orchestration
framework that we've developed now which
is a little bit of in-house stuff. We'll
cover kind of what the differences are
but a lot more feature sets.
So how we're doing evaluations. The best
way for us to to go into this our
thought process was we need to know what
we're looking for so that we can
benchmark against it. Right? So we need
to highlight the vulnerabilities and
have a set list of things that are known
vans but also the the set list of
pitfalls right so we need false
positives we need dead code we need
commonly misinterpreted paths and
vulnerability pass vulnerability classes
as well as automated metrics gathering
so we can just keep running these tests
and figuring out what's working for us
because you might change one line in the
prompt it's a genius now you change it
again it's terrible um you add one tool
it works great for the first run second
run it doesn't um so we're continuing to
work on that
>> yeah and I I want to take folks back
like do you remember I'm curious in the
audience like the first time you fired
up like an IDE assistant or generative
AI assistant and found some
vulnerabilities. Can folks raise a hand.
Just kind of curious like it was a
pretty amazing moment for me. I I
remember finding like I couldn't believe
it found serverside request forgery. It
found unsafe serialization. It felt
magical. And that was like you know a
year ago. But then like I'd run into
issues like this where all of a sudden
my I was using root code at the time and
it would just abort a large session and
I'd lose the entire history of my prompt
or you didn't update this context file.
You're supposed to do this. You're
right. I ignored your instructions and
have fun not knowing what
vulnerabilities we found. Or this is a
good one. This is just like a gray
screen that happened uh in rue code. I
lost the entire coding session. Um or
maybe you miss 12 true positives or you
get incorrect severity because several
findings aren't even reachable. just
sometimes would skip entire vone classes
and it's kind of frustrating and so you
know what we wanted to really do is take
this evaluation and testing based
approach um because what we noticed is
that when models change uh so do the
best configurations for the results that
we're looking for. We have a huge set of
hypotheses that we're going to run
through today. I'm not going to verbatim
read this slide. Uh one thing I'll draw
your attention to is that in the middle
of this talk opus 4.6 six special grade
curse dropped and um uh during our talk
prep and we've been kind of wondering if
like all the 12-hour days the last few
months were actually worth it and it is
but maybe for different reasons than you
think. I want to start out with the
first experiment. Singular security
agent versus specialized agents. And so
here we had this hypothesis that
specialized agents would find more bugs
given focused objectives. And so I'll
draw your attention in the top left is
our orchestrated DB. You'll see this
variant continue to show up. This is our
best case uh workflow that we'll
describe near the end of the talk. TP is
true positive and cost. I'll highlight
in green the the sections of the metrics
that we're going to be looking at today.
So our super agent is effectively just a
giant monolithic rule file with a tons
of security context and the reality is
is that uh we're targeting 41 true
positives for our evaluation benchmark
and super agent found about 36 of them
for a much cheaper cost. So what we
identify is that with claude sonnet as
an example um having a monolithic agent
is cost effective but a multi- aent uh
configuration finds more true positives.
The next thing we looked at was
dedicated false positive uh and triage
filtering. And we had this hypothesis
that having false positive and triage in
their own agents would be more effective
than inter agent determinis
determinations. So in this example on
the on the top left we see here's an
orchestrated scan that has no false
positive checking. And when we evaluated
our score sheet, we noticed it had 26%
severity uh correct severity assignments
um as opposed to running an orchestrated
scan with a dedicated false positive
agent resulted in 74%. So uh I would
generally recommend like dedicated post
analysis. It's definitely worthwhile.
It's worth the the little bit of extra
tokens because you'll get correct
severity assignments which will help you
with triage. Next we're going to talk
through similar vass grouping versus
individual agents. We had this
hypothesis that like if we group agents
into categories um something like uh
network bugs or injection
vulnerabilities that we'd save tokens
and have pretty good coverage. We were
totally wrong on this one. Um the
reality was uh when we broke them into
categories instead of running them
individually. Uh we only found 34 out of
the 41 vulnerabilities. Now the cost was
a lot. It saves a lot of tokens, but it
has a super high miss rate. My general
recommendation, don't use categories.
Oh, and we also think it may be
overfitting on category names. Super
interesting. Um, so something worth
exploring as well. All right.
Enumeration, discovery, and tracing.
These are stages of the workflow that
we're going to be describing that we
believe would would help us, you know,
save tokens and improve costs by just
skipping unnecessary files, only loading
agents that are relevant for the
architecture, and tracing sources and
syncs. If you've attended nine out of 10
talks, we've been talking a lot about
tracing in this conference. And lo and
behold, that's actually true. It looks
like when we bring in thoughtful context
management uh to the agents that it's
about a 26% cost reduction on most of
our runs. Uh which is pretty exciting.
Um and we get better depth uh overall is
is our hypothesis there. So wanted to
talk through forced file evaluation or
batching. This is the concept of giving
every agent effectively like line by
line requirements uh that they have to
fulfill so we can cover every single
line of code. And for folks that have
worked in consulting, you know that like
if you're an engineer, that's on an
engagement, that could be like months of
work. So it's expensive. It works really
well. Um, but it costs a lot of money.
And so this is an example where like if
you want to have the agent scan every
line of code, um, maybe you only do that
for your most critical code bases. Maybe
you only do that if you get a signal
from a lighter scan that there's some
code smells and something you might want
to dig in dig into, but it's definitely
expensive. All right, so let's talk
about some not so fun moments. Um, I
remember spending like half a day trying
to get uh a claw.p experiment going and
didn't realize it didn't support custom
tools. So had to throw it away. Um, it
was really fun to like run a 45minute
plus scan and then see this autocompact
at 0% and just like my heart drops cuz
I'm like, "Oh my gosh, am I going to
lose fidelity in my scan results?" I
don't know, Justice, like what are some
of your favorites?
>> Yeah. Um, I'll definitely say that, uh,
one of my favorites was, um, realizing
that we've got, you know, starting to
get some really good comprehensive
coverage from some of the architectural
choices we made and we're watching the
findings come in and we're watching the
coverage and the tracing and I'm like,
oh my gosh, this is beautiful. And I'm
like, it's still running. The tokens are
still increasing and you realize that
someone's going to get an alert from a
pricing model and have to leap across
the desk for a quick control C. Um, and
then also this upper right hand corner
is my uh cloud code turning into a
JavaScript pile for whatever reason and
losing everything. So
>> yeah, always great to when your cloud
code just decides to turn pink. How fun
is that? We also had some fun moments.
We've been doing a set of disclosures,
responsible disclosures and and
submitting PRs to popular projects. Sort
of our filter for the projects we were
choosing was over 5,000 stars and is
most likely a remote API, something that
we would sort of see in a first party
like envir environment. Uh, one of the
vulnerabilities I was the most excited
to have us discover was a double spend,
a time of check, time of use
vulnerability in a trading platform. It
allowed you to get free money. Those are
my favorite hacks of all time. I don't
know, Justice, how about you?
>> Yeah. Um, definitely a couple. I think
one was really interesting for
potentially for like internal
assessments, internal penetration
testing. We found essent a command
injection vulnerability in a VIP stack.
So, it amounted to being we'll say RC
arbitrary rce over uh over fax, which is
pretty cool. Um, and then, uh, I'll say
this upper right hand corner, this
unnamed developer, this was we reported
a couple of vulnerabilities, pretty high
severity, and noticed that we're getting
closed and card called, well, we'll say
garbage, not nice names. And then, this
is not their name, by the way. Don't
harass whoever has this actual handle on
GitHub. Um, but we went back and we're
like, I wonder what they did. They
patched all of them. So, shout out to
you for
there was like and then there was a lot
of late nights over our research thing.
Here's me at like 8:00 at night for
Justice. That's like 10 cuz he's in
central time. I'm like super confused
and sad. Um because like sometimes when
we were working on the baselining I just
didn't understand why things were
looking different. I was like was it me?
And that made it really comp
complicated. I wanted to find out for
you.
>> Yeah. And I think like one thing that
you have to all realize is like these
tests will continue to change and that's
why it's important for us to keep
running them because every once in a
while the model will just seem to append
a couple more brain cells and you're
like I solved everything. We are the
best. This is phenomenal. And then the
next five runs will look a little bit
different. So
>> yeah, and then you know at one point I
get this ping from Justice in the
morning. He's like, "Hey, did you see
Opus4.6 dropped?" And it's likeun
um and we want to actually walk you
through a little bit of what we found.
So Opus.4.6 on a small codebase.
Absolutely fantastic. Uh think about
codebase maybe have one or two thousand
lines of code. Uh we found that with a
little bit of you know crafty prompting
that we could get close to 41 true
positives. Uh about 38 on average which
is exciting. However, things really
change when we start to get the large
code bases. Think code bases over 30,000
lines of code or over 125 files. On the
left, audience left. Yep. On the left,
you'll see um Opus in a solo mode here.
And um it found of the expected 191 on
our extra large codebase, 40 true
positives, while the super agent uh
effectively just a monolithic prompt
with a less powerful model found 80. And
if we orchestrate that into a workflow,
we find 116. So what does this really
suggest? I think it suggests for large
code bases being really thoughtful about
your context management in your workflow
can result in higher fidelity results
even more than a really powerful model
like opus. There might be a way to get
all the way there. So if you're a person
who's like I can find all the way to get
all the way there. Come talk to us. We'd
love to learn more. Just why don't you
walk us through the workflow?
>> Yeah. So um this is essentially the
workflow like architecture and
orchestration that we've been working on
internally. So heavy heavy heavy focus
on like programmatic determinism where
we can. So think you know when you're
walking the file tree for the repository
omitting things like tests build
artifacts examples things like that that
we don't want the models to be
processing in all use cases and then
focusing on the ones that we do. um that
discovery and priming phase is looking
for you know we're leveraging all the
tools in our kit right so think um think
a think l think uh regular expressions
think sem think codeql think all these
things that are going to enable these
models to have a better trace and
understanding and comprehension of the
actual codebase themselves we want to do
all that first so that we can better
prioritize downstream so we call like
discovery gates we're only going to open
up for models that have matching
architectures or agents rather that
match the architecture we're not going
to scan for SQL injection if there's no
database things like that. And then
we're also not going to feed syncs and
file prioritization to the agents that
have no relevance. So we're not going to
feed HTML output and DOMB based syncs to
the SQL injection agent because we don't
want it to prioritize looking there. Um
so cutting that out has helped us a ton
and enables us to set when Scott was
talking about that file batching. We're
actually batching files together and
feeding them to the agents based on that
sync prioritization and then also based
on file relationships. So if you get
five files, all the files should have
cross imports and cross usage so that
the analysis is able to do its thing
without having to do too much additional
exploration and suck up those tokens
unfortunately, right? Um, and then we
have some other additional stuff
downstream where, you know, we're
focusing on schematization, programmatic
tool calling, so that if the agent
hallucinates the severity of urgency or
hallucinates a vulnerability class of
chocolate rain, all the programmatic
enforcement kicks in and it forces it to
iterate and and re-evaluate its
assessment and and fit to the
constraints and like for example like an
enum of all the things that we actually
want it to be doing. And then we're also
not expanding and giving every agent
every tool. The data tracing agent
doesn't need access to the same amount
of tools that all the other agents have,
right? So it's very different. Um, and
then we also are kicking in that that
false positive and triage phase so that
we're only looking at the things that
really matter to us. And we found that
that's a really really phenomenal
workflow.
>> So, let's go ahead and do a little bit
of a demo. Step your laptop, dude.
Sorry. Uh, and let me go ahead and pull
up my
demo video here and we'll step through
this. Sweet. Cool. All right. So, I'll
pause real quick. So, this is going to
be a demo of effectively a CLI version
of the skills and references that we're
releasing today. The reason this isn't a
CLI and we're not releasing it is
because I wanted all the verbose output
so that we could talk through it, but
the skills run in subtasks and stuff.
So, it's a little bit harder to see. Um,
but effectively functionally the same.
We're going to be scanning a really
simple simple Flask application has just
a couple vulnerability classes in it.
And the first phase of what we're doing
here is file enumeration. We're
filtering out tests and git and large
images, things we just don't need to
scan. And that really helps us kind of
manage the sort of front end of the
context. After we've done that
enumeration, we step into three phases
here. A phase two, it's a combination of
static analysis, uh discovery of the
architecture, and data flow tracing to
identify sources and syncs to
investigate. Um, we run these in
parallel because they actually don't
have any dependency on each other. And
that allows us to do things a little
faster. So, you'll see in the bottom
here that we're starting to dismiss
candidates. It's because it's not in
source or it's in a comment or it's not
reachable. It's just context that we
don't have to get to the model because
it doesn't actually matter. But as we
continue our process of tracing those
vulnerabilities from start to finish, we
identify a few data flows such as a
request parameter that shows up in HTML
output or a database read that shows up
in HTML output. And those are exciting
for us. We want to definitely follow up
on those. Now, we're also collecting
metrics duration LM calls. One thing
I'll mention for the audience here is is
um we often find that sometimes a small
tweak to an agent rule could cut down
your context by 15% or more. So it's
like worth it to to have a good sense of
what your agents are doing and be making
adjustments along the way. Also
disabling noisy agents. So coverage gate
aka discovery is like what is the
architecture? To justice's point, if
it's not doing templating, we don't need
to load in a serverside template
injection agent. And so once we've kind
of understood the architecture uh
deterministically, we're using again GP
and and other tools. We start to run
mandatory and relevant agents. Mandatory
agents run every single time. relevant
are like depending on the architecture
we're going to pull these in. These
agents run in parallel because again
they don't have dependency on each
other. So we see a cross-ite scripting
and a SQL injection agent. Crossite
scripting agent has identified two
crossite scripting vulnerabilities
reflected cross-ite scripting
vulnerability as well as a stored
cross-ite scripting vulnerability. And
once we've kind of finished that
scanning we dduplicate findings and we
corroborate those. If we're running
static analysis tooling and the LM finds
it, that's interesting. um we might want
to follow up and that might be a signal
that it's a true positive. And once
we've kind of gone through this uh
cross-ite scripting flow and
dduplication, the SQL injection um agent
eventually finishes and finds two
instances of SQL I as an example. Um so
we step into false positive remediation
and triage. Our false positive agent
actually identified that um that this
event type parameter is actually
validated against an allow list before
reaching the SQL query. That effectively
means only predefined safe values can
pass through. So it's not a SQL
injection we really need to look at.
That's great if we're triaging a lot of
vulnerabilities. We really want to focus
on our time on the bugs that matter.
Once we've gone through that, uh we'll
talk a little bit about the triaging
process. I think in the conference
there's been a lot of talks on
vulnerability management life cycles. We
refer to triage as like we're the team
responding and so for us it's like how
quickly can I validate these findings.
Um if it's a timing based attack
validation might take a lot more time
where as opposed to in this example we
have a reflected cross- sight scripting
that has these factors single request
observable output really easy for me to
validate those and I'll tell you the
truth if I have like 30 crits I don't
want to start with the most complicated
one because I want that dopamine. So I'm
going to go absolutely go after the ones
that are the easiest and the fastest to
validate. The last thing you'll see here
is um on our stored cross- sight
scripting uh it's a multi-step flow and
observable output. And so what this kind
of reflects is we can use all these
facets to sort of determine our triage
strategy. And with that I will go ahead
and present let's see here our reference
release repo. So um this is kind of a
combination of uh several skills that
we've used for running these
experiments. Uh, we're going to include
our evaluation repos with scoreheets
that you can use for testing out your
tooling. I think one thing that we felt
like has maybe been missing in the
evaluation world is that we're
evaluating base models, but that's just
not how folks are running them in
production. We're often running them in
workflows. We're often running them with
custom harnesses. So, we hope that this
context sort of fills a current gap that
will help you all test your workflows.
And then finally, we'll release a subset
of agents that we've been using with
pretty good success. And with that,
thank you. Any
questions?
>> Justice, you mentioned that um you will
get kind of differing results um like
the you know agent added some brain
cells.
>> Yeah. Um, did you play around with uh
agent sequencing or repetition to see if
your results varied and then what did
you find?
>> Yeah. So, if I'm understanding you
correctly, you're saying like doing like
iterations of the scan with the same
agent like in the same scanning context.
>> Yeah. Or even reordering the sort of
agent workflows.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah, definitely. Um, I think we
we've tried a fair number of different
things. Um, and happy to brain dump if
if you're curious. I think some of the
things that we're really looking at
going forward would be chaining of
agents of varying complexity and cost.
So for example like this might not be
the ones we would choose but say we like
haiku is very cheap right? So chaining
those into the more advanced agents so
that we can get multiple iterations
before we go on. I think one of the
previous talks that we watched was
saying you know like Opus is very good
but it's not so much better in some of
these use cases that it's worth the
additional cost where you know maybe
there are certain triggers that we would
want to layer where we would say like
haiku to certain triggers to sonnet to
certain triggers to opus to certain
triggers and just take over the context
window with that additional more
advanced agent and those are definitely
things we've tried. It does come out to
be a lot better results. It also does
come out to be a lot more expensive. Um,
so weighing the differences and kind of
determining what works best for your
environment is kind of where we're at
because, you know, if you want to scan
every line of code, we can definitely do
that. We'll find tons of vulnerabilities
every time. The issue is if you're okay
with, you know, $400, $500 per repo, per
scan. It just depends on the scalability
and the importance of the repo, for
sure.
>> All right, before we get to another
question, if you're the next speaker,
can you come up and see this gentleman
over here on the opposite side of the
stage and he'll get you set up?
All right, I'll go right here in the
middle.
um security prompting and getting the
right results is hard. Any tips or
tricks that you have used which will
give you the results that you need?
>> Yeah, sure. Um I think you know I both
of us come from like an offensive
security background. So a lot of exploit
development, a lot of red teaming, a lot
of penetration testing. Um we tend to
provide the prompts in a way that our
logic would work as well. Um so giving
it all the ground rules and then being
explicit I think about what you don't
want it to do while giving it the
flexibility to evolve. So rather than
saying like here are all the vulnerable
patterns it would be something like here
are the vulnerable patterns to reference
ensure you take into account application
context to evolve and to do additional
discovery because there are variance
right so ensuring you're explicit so the
models don't take your word as gospel is
>> yeah and maybe one other sort of uh
thing that we've noticed is that the
models are trained based on a volume of
data I think everybody in this audience
knows SQL injection but does everybody
know time of check time of use there's
way less articles in time of check time
of To give you an example, re very
rarely have we actually seen Opus find
meaningful time of check time of use
without having time of check time of use
in its prompt. So when you think about
the hundreds and hundreds of
vulnerability classes, if you're only
looking for OAS top 10 with a vanilla
model, you'll find it. But the minute
you start stepping into more esoteric
vulnerabilities, providing that context
in a vanilla prompt or in a workflow
results in significantly better coverage
based on the way that the models are
trained.
>> Anybody else?
>> One other question. We got time for one
more right here.
>> Um, hi. So, this seems like a longunning
background scan that I presume you run
every like day or week or so. Do you
have a separate sort of surface for like
PRs or And do the scans build on top of
each other?
>> You want me to cover that?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, we actually So, we
have an MCP that we leverage as well.
Um, and our intention with that was to
like have that trigger on pull requests.
Um, we also have this incremental diff
feature that I think just has developed
on our internal approach which like when
a diff occurs we have the ability to
just scan that diff. Um, kind of our
philosophy for scanning this right now
is is um is trying to when we do a scan
get it as close to developer as possible
and then on our most critical code bases
like do really comprehensive coverage
and then just go more work closely with
those teams. So we've had I mean we're
in the process of getting the PR stuff
sort of working now. I don't have a
great update on how how some of the pain
points we're going to find there, but
that's something we are actively working
on.
>> Yeah. And I I'll just add like one of
the things that we're seeing works well
for that is if we're trying to constrain
context and constrain token usage is
we're saving all of the traces and data
that we're talking about right now as
well as the findings and all the
resulting logic. So we're tracking like
when the model makes a decision to call
something a false positive, what it did
and why it did it. So keeping all that
information so that when we are
reviewing PRs, our plan is to feed that
in. so that we don't actually have to
reevaluate the entire codebase and we
can have enough context for it to make
the decision. Do I need to do any
additional exploration for like
regressions or additional downstream
vulnerability chains? Um so that we
don't have to do the full scan again.
Thank you.
>> Thanks a lot guys.